Here's a picture of what the visitor pattern looks like, there of
course is a client class, which is going to lead the operations to be applied.
And then two categories of other classes.
One is a category having to do with the data structure itself and
the other is a category of classes having to do with the visitors.
As far as the data structure is concerned,
there will be some kind of abstract element and then
concrete elements corresponding to the different parts of the data structure.
The abstract element provides an abstract method called
accept with an argument visitor.
That is, as you are navigating through the data structure and
you want to apply the operations you send the visitor,
as an object, to each of the elements you come to.
And it must accept that visitor, and
essentially call back to the visitor to perform the operations.